there was a case in Detroit this person
is explained to compatriot why he had
picked one of the largest churches in
the Detroit area to attacked and this
church had banned anybody from having
permanent concealed handguns on church
property and he explained to his
compatriot that that made it easier for
him to kill lots of people before
anybody could arrive so this man is
actually written the book the war on
guns so you can imagine why we would
want to have him on right now I can
follow him on the Twitter at John our
lot l OTT jr. mr. John lot thank you for
being here sir
it's great to talk to you thanks for
having me on
well we're super glad to have you on so
I know listen I mean we've talked about
guns quite a bit and you and I were just
talking off air about how it's a
surprisingly winning issue with younger
people and often a lot of people on the
right aren't aware of just how much of a
winning issue it is we've we've had to
run ins with Vox and I know that you
have so let's start with this right now
obviously this gun debate is being I
mean so much of it is just it's it's a
quagmire let's start separating it piece
by piece with you sir the expert Vox
wrote a recent article America's unique
gun violence problem and you basically
deconstructed it point by point how
about you take us through that and what
that experience was like well they've
had I guess the post with like seventeen
charts where they go and they claim that
the United States has is unique in terms
of gun violence that were unique in
terms of the rate that people own guns
in the country and obviously they draw a
connection between the two indicating
that we could only get rid of the guns
we'd end up reducing the level violence
in the United States there's so many
kind of different levels of problems
with it I mean people don't even
understand that there is a difference
between murder and homicide right they
don't they use data in ways that just is
not kosher that you know academics
wouldn't go and use and I can happy to
talk about it but you know so for
example murder and homicide most people
don't know
that the difference between the two is
justifiable homicides homicides are
murders plus cases where either police
or civilians use guns to protect
themselves and so you know in a typical
year recently you would have had maybe
about 8,000 firearm murders but you'd
have maybe 12,000 firearm homicides and
they don't know how large of a share
that the vast majority of those fire
armor ders are gang-related right what
do you think they don't know at this
point I mean you're an academic and some
of them at Vox can be argued are
academics do you think they don't not
like a bomb on the MIT on the wage myth
yes it's like President Obama on the
wage gap you're going or is he trying to
push a message do you really think they
don't know at this point or they're so
entrenched in the agenda that they have
to continue with it because I know your
research shows the opposite might be
true which I'd like to get into right
well I mean it's hard to get in people's
heads to know what's actually motivating
them on things you know there are lots
of prominent cases where numbers are put
out where I just know they're fraudulent
you know so I suppose one of the more
prominent examples there's this guy
named Adam Langford who has put together
data
he says mass public shootings around the
world claiming that the United States
makes up about 1/3 of the mass shootings
around the world but only 4% of the
world's population
I've been asking for the guys data since
they got attention in 2015 I mean when
it came out he had the front page top
above the fold of every major newspaper
in the country and most the minor ones
yeah he got coverage in at least 30
different countries that the man would
hold in in the back your iPhone 4% know
your apps you know it's funny that you
bring that up because we've done this
quite a bit and they don't send their
sources but I've not heard that one
before I know it's false right away
because of the research we've done when
you look at mass shootings in places
like the Honduras and South American
countries and let's see here's the
so they look at mass public shootings of
four more people right in the United
States you're going to get all the cases
but you know so he's looking at data
from the 1960s through 2012 does anybody
really believe that you're going to be
able to find all the mass public
shootings in in Africa or South America
or Central America in the late 60s right
in the 70s I mean it's not like jeepers
yeah it's not like their newspapers were
even online at the time yeah and half
the archive you're not alone away by
Kony in Africa there's no way to get it
I can't imagine and and no one called
him on his claim well the thing is the
media doesn't care about it I just been
going back and forth with some people at
the New York Times because they just a
few months ago ran a huge full page
showing graphs that he had from his data
the thing is the graphs are unusable to
try to figure it out because they don't
label the dots and the vast majority of
dots are kind of all scrambled together
so you can't figure out what the with
the number he's claiming for individual
countries so I'd like to get information
on the actual cases that he has or if
that doesn't work which they won't give
you at least tell me the number of cases
he's claiming by country but they won't
do that yes and in the reporters they
don't care they won't they don't ask so
the thing with the New York Times that
Langford had told the New York Times are
told us that he had given the New York
Times exclusivity now you're dealing
with the media exclusivity with you on
gun violence it's not a scoop right
nobody even if even if somehow you had
giving them exclusivity it would just be
to let them run it first right you're
not gonna go and say well I'm gonna give
the newspaper exclusivity for five
months or for you know perpetuity after
that right and then when we contact the
New York Times they said well you have
to get it from Langford that they
weren't gonna give it out to us I don't
know why but they you know it just
that's afraid I have to protect my
sources what do you do if CDs like it's
a CD
except it's not so anyway just there's
so many things out there and well let me
ask you this you know lately what would
you say the most the most repeated false
point in the gun control narrative right
now if you had to zoning unlike on one
and we can go to number two and three
but what would you say is most important
for people to know I suppose maybe the
simplest thing is just how do you make
comparisons across places so you'll see
people say we'll look the United Kingdom
has very strict gun control
very few guns are owned and yet and they
have a low homicide rate compared to the
United States and and they say therefore
that means that it's the strict gun
control that's causing the low crime
right there the problem is is that if
you look before they had the gun control
laws they had an even lower homicide
rate right that when they passed the
different gun control laws their
homicide rate went up it was still lower
than the United States but given that it
was even lower before they had the gun
control laws it's hard to go and say
they have a low homicide rate because of
the gun control laws there's obviously
other things that vary across countries
and places that are accounting for the
difference there I feel as though
they've moved even away from that you
can correct me if I'm wrong but again we
deal in this world quite a bit with with
Vox and with a you know HuffPo and of
course they points the Australian
mandatory buyback they don't tell you
it's a mandatory buyback you know
because no one wants to take your guns
away by the way in case you were
paranoid but um they've moved away it
seems from from for example gun homicide
they've moved entirely just to gun
related homicide because the violent
crime rates are actually worse in a lot
of these countries with strict gun
control we see yes and so I mean a lot
of countries don't report murder rates
right and also one of the things is that
there's a much bigger difference between
homicides and murders in the United
States than there is most other
countries we have people defend
themselves more here in the United
States and so you have you know a bigger
gap that's there but you mentioned the
Australian stuff the Australia stuff you
know I don't know hoax or whatever it's
just complete missing for me
so I'll just give you a simple example
they'll go and they'll say that firearm
homicides were lower after the 96-97 by
back then they were before but and
that's true but the thing is it was
falling for 15 years prior to the
buyback and it was falling afterwards
but at a slower rate right and so you
know if it were falling at a faster rate
or there was a kind of a big downward
jump right at that time it would make
more sense but if it's falling before I
mean if you have a straight line and
it's falling over the entire period you
could pick any year right and the after
average would be below the before
average you wouldn't take that as
evidence that any of those years were
somehow crucial for changing the levels
that were occurring there in terms of
firearm homicides the other thing is
that's never mentioned it's true they
had this big buyback about a third of
the guns were bought back in 96 and 97
but people were then able to go out and
buy guns again and by 2010 the gun
ownership rate in Australia was actually
above what it was prior to the buyback
so if if they're right about this what
you should have seen is a big sharp
immediate drop and then an increase over
time and that's not what you observe wha
we've written about that quite a bit and
isn't it also true that you see the same
trend in New Zealand which would be the
most comparable country as well during
that same period of time and they didn't
have the mandatory buyback well you
definitely exactly where you don't see
it in terms of the mass public shooting
I mean you see you see the same trend in
terms of mass public shootings look New
Zealand actually had a bigger drop in
the rate of mass public shootings at the
same time than Australia did and yet
they didn't pass any laws that would be
related to this exactly Hobbit trilogy
was released so people were on you know
it's across countries a good example of
that as infant mortality rates you know
we've talked about this with health care
quite a bit when people try to bring up
socialized health care they said well
these other countries spend less than
better really the only the only
barometer that's used when they're
talking about that are our poll is
polling data by subjective measurements
where they ask people are you satisfied
with your health care and people say yes
but if you look at wait times in
emergency rooms the United States is
better if you look at mortality rates
from serious illnesses objective
empirical data empirical data would say
yes which isn't necessarily the realm
sometimes of our political opposition
when they're dealing with these topics
have you have you find it hard found it
hard to find someone who's willing to
step up like you said with these sources
but to have a conversation or debate
because another New York Times just ran
today a piece saying how to deal how to
have the gun control argument today I
don't know if you saw this in the
opinion page and I was going on a second
you didn't just have an argument you
just wrote an op-ed you still have yet
to have an argument yeah look I'll tell
you the gun control people have an
agreement among themselves not to debate
me and the you know I think there are a
couple reasons for that one is for TV
shows they'll usually want to have
people from both sides and if everybody
from the different gun control groups
don't want to debate me I mean I can't
tell you the number of times they'll get
a call from CNN or somebody be driving
into the studio and I'm like five
minutes away from the studio and I'll
get a call from the producer saying well
we're gonna have to go a different
direction you know none of the bloomberg
people when we told them that you were
going to be on the air by you know said
that they we had to get somebody else
they said they'd rather wore a guy who
was a former Republican and supports
sensible gun control measures that's a
better conversation we're gonna go with
that one
let me ask you this since we can't
compare across different countries and
I've talked we can we can look at things
across countries but you have to do in a
particular way so for example I'll give
you a simple question that is can you
name me one place in the world that's
ban guns either all guns or all handguns
and see murder rates fall or even stay
the same every single place that's
banned guns he had seen increase is
often very large
increases in in murder rates and I would
say deadpan that's the example they
often use and I know the answer but I
figured I'd toss it out there right well
the thing is with Japan you want to look
before and after they have the gun
control laws
Japan's had a low murder rate as long as
we have numbers from them and they've
had very strict gun control laws since
the 1700s only samurai were basically
legally able to go and own guns so you
know you want to have something where we
can say you know like when the UK banned
handguns and January 97 their homicide
rate went up 50 percent over the next
eight years you see similar increases so
you look at island nations because gun
control advocates will say okay well
it's true but murder and violent crime
went up in Chicago and in Washington DC
after we had bands but that's not really
a fair comparison they'll say because
people go and get guns from you know
rest of Illinois or Indiana or Maryland
or Virginia the thing is that doesn't
explain why it went up right people
could buy guns from those places
beforehand it may explain why I didn't
go down as they were predicting though
if they really believed that that caused
it to go up to be kind of nice if they
had shared that secret with people
before the bans were passed right but
but even if you look at island nations
that can't go and blame a neighbor you
see every single time that you've had a
band murder rates have gone up often you
know five six seven fold after bans have
been placed and turns out they say
murder as opposed to homicide I want to
make sure we're getting well I mean both
murder and homicide depending upon how
the place measures it not everybody
measures murder but you see an increase
in both of those and and for most
countries murder and homicide are much
more close to each other than is true in
the United States right but you know you
think it would cause gun control
advocates some pause you know usually
the response you'll get back is well
we're not talking about banning guns but
but the one is I'm not I don't believe
that I think they would like the banned
guns if they could but to the point
stands for other laws you have to ask
yourself who is most likely to obey the
different gun control laws that you have
the reason why murder rates go up after
bans is that it's the most law-abiding
good citizens who turn in their guns not
the criminals so much and to the extent
that you disarm law-abiding citizens
relative to criminals you actually make
it easier for them to go and commit
crimes in it that's true for gun control
generally so I'm not to mention the
moral reprehensibility of forbidding
someone their god-given right to protect
themselves it to me is immoral to say
well this woman has never had to defend
herself because David Hogg was on CNN
once but one thing I would like to kind
of hone in on here we just talked about
different countries but something they
bring up I know they bring up quite a
bit no Vox has done this I'd like to ask
you do states so now for stateside where
we have obviously a consistent
measurement homicides murders do states
overall you just listed Chicago but
states with stricter gun control laws
can they argue that states with stricter
gun control laws have lower gun crime
overall or oh yeah no the opposite is
clearly true what you have to do is
essentially deal with the same point
that we dealt with when we're talking
about the UK you have to deal with what
were the different crime rates across
these places or murder rates before they
had these gun laws and to see how they
change after they've adopted them so you
want to kind of pull out kind of the
pre-existing average differences across
places and as soon as you do that you
see in fact that the places with the
stricter gun control laws have I have
much higher murder rates that are there
much higher homicide rates much higher
overall gun deaths you know even if you
include suicides in there well what
would we use as examples as far as
states or cities with those kinds of
laws and high high of violent crime
rates well the point is how it changes
kind of before and after if they go to
the post that we put up on responding to
the box then because you're right that's
one of the things that they put up there
we have a diagram that basically
uses something from the Brady Campaign
which is a gun control group every year
since 2001 they put out an index of gun
control laws in different places in
different states and you could see very
clearly that as states have had their
you know number of gun control laws
increase you'll see an increase in the
homicides or firearm homicides or
murders however you want to break it
down the lucious outlaws in the country
live alone knows is Vermont Vermont two
are the losses Vermont is the one place
in the country I think maybe Arizona now
but you can purchase a firearm from
Vermont in Vermont then you can carry it
open or concealed try and open artery
verse all that alright yeah but that's
for optics yeah I up until literally
just less I guess now Vermont has had no
other state gun control laws on its own
the only gun control laws there are the
federal laws that are there but you have
fourteen states now that have similar
types of concealed carry laws to Vermont
where you don't need to have a permit to
carry within those states they're twelve
states which are exactly like Vermont
where you don't need to have a permit to
carry any place in the state and then
there are two other states Montana and
Arkansas where you don't need to have
permit in the vast majority of the state
but in some places you do and you know
most these states laws are fairly recent
but you know just like little concealed
carry to begin with there hasn't been
the types of bad things that people been
claiming and you know the big benefit of
this is is who benefits the most from
caring and my research indicates it's
basically the people most likely be
victims of violent crime and that
overwhelmingly tends to be poor blacks
who live in high crime urban areas so
you have a state like Illinois they
allow concealed carry now but it costs
about four hundred fifty dollars to go
through the process to go and get a
concealed carry permit well who do you
think you're stopping from gay
a concealed carry permit when it cost
$450 and it's just not the cost it's
illegal to go and carry even a permit
concealed handgun on public
transportation there are no training
places in the city of Chicago so if
you're a poor person then you have to
get 16 hours of training it's kind of if
they checked off every box is it
expensive yes do we make it so that you
can't take public transportation to go
there yes are there no training
facilities anywhere near remotely close
to where you live that we allow yes
you know it's saying what can we do here
to make it so that the very people poor
blacks who are most likely to be victims
of violent crime can't qualify to go and
legally carry a concealed handgun you
know you have these so-called
constitutional states you know those
places you know these people are going
to be able to carry and you look at a
state like Pennsylvania for example it's
$20 to go and get a concealed carry
permit you see a very big different mix
of people who go and get a permit you
know in Illinois so you get a lot of
wealthy whites who live in the suburbs
to be able to go and carry well that's
nice but they're not the ones who are
most likely to be threatened with
violent crime and so you don't see as
big of a drop in terms of violent crime
from people caring for two reasons one
not as many people carry when it's very
expensive to get a permit but two you're
not having the right people carry right
that's an interesting point were you
gonna say something I was just I think
Pennsylvania actually has the largest
number of concealed carry holders I
think in the states I'm not sure if
that's per capita right that's 400 well
Florida Florida has the most of good
Pennsylvania second second okay so
Pennsylvania I think right now is about
1.4 million concealed carry permit
holders nationwide you have about
seventeen million concealed carry permit
holders yes yeah yeah you know I'm with
that isn't that really quickly if I may
interject because we've right now we see
obviously the children out there
speaking about this and we kind of tied
to these social justice movements are
tied together and of course gun culture
gun owners they've brought out these
this is this is basically a a white man
culture here in the United States the
gun culture but really that's that's
sort of self perpetuated by the left as
you're talking about because of these
roadblocks and that's something I've
always found interesting that's never
really brought up well it's because a
lot of these suburban white men can
afford it and they don't live in
inner-city Chicago they don't live in
these areas
no it's an important point look you look
nationwide you get about 11 percent a
little bit over 11% 12% of of concealed
carry permit holders are black for the
states that we have that data you look
at some place like Los Angeles where I
was able to get at the actual list of
permit holders there you know they have
fewer than 300 permits for a county of 8
million people but blacks only have
about 6% of the permit holders that are
there nationwide women make up about 32%
of permit holders but in Los Angeles
they make up only about 7% of permit
holders is that because of the kind of
old boys network yeah I mean my brother
lives there you have to get a sheriff's
permission it's a lengthy process so
you're in 8 of these states you have to
go and get some public official either
you know a politician a judge a sheriff
a police department to go and let you
have decide if you can carry a permit
and the thing is these are
overwhelmingly democratic areas and yet
the Republican areas have high rates of
blacks being able to carry in women but
the places where you have to get
permission from a Democrat to be able to
go and carry they basically give it to
white males they don't give it to they
you know you have to go and give them a
good reason to be able to go in theory
and living in a dangerous area isn't
considered to be a good reason yeah and
living in watts living in Inglewood that
should be reason case closed they get in
in LA you have to prove that you are
carrying so much money sometimes - yes
that's a big part of one of the barriers
to entry I think it's if you're carrying
something that would eliminate a lot of
probably women and black families is it
is it the number is it something like
$10,000 mr. lot you need
you need to prove that you are either
carrying that amount of war equipment or
worth that much it's subjective you know
there's no hard and fast rule that's
there and I guess that's part of the
problem you know in New York City also
you have a similar thing they you have
to go and get permission from the New
York City Police Department to be able
to go and get a permit so you have to go
and give them a good reason and yeah you
can look at the list of people there's
like the publisher for the New York
Times there's some famous radio show
hosts you have heads of labor unions I
have sealed carry permits well you know
it's nice I'm glad those people are able
to go and protect themselves they feel
that the need to be able to go and do it
but it's a little bit ironic that
somebody like the publisher for the New
York Times understands the desire for
himself to be able to go and protect
himself but some poor person who lives
in Harlem you know there's like zero
chance that they're going to be allowed
to get a concealed carry permit you look
at the they have it by zip code for the
permits that they've given out there and
it's people on the Upper West Side
you know the very wealthy Swank areas
where you see all the concealed carry
permits given out not not the people who
actually are in the highest risks of
being killed right yes it really good
examples Illinois where we just did a
show we went on campus we had to cancel
the show in the theater because the
campus police wouldn't show up even if
we paid them they said nah no one's
gonna there's no credible threat well I
mean you know we actually we have plenty
of credible threats and we've had some
seaweed own want to Edo have any
copycats out there I think it's pretty
well known him on the ISIS kill list
like that's kind of a threat let's start
with that so they wouldn't show up even
if we paid them and then we had some
off-duty officers who had a security
firm who we paid out of her pocket to
show up so we could do a smaller show
and the campus police were to say
they're not allowed to carry so we
actually took all over their head with a
state official who said of course you
can carry as an off-duty officer so they
really do try and set themselves up as a
barrier to entry and that was a great
example where we felt totally helpless
we were going on a second the armed
police on campus won't show up we can't
get 1200 people we're going
we'll show up we can't pay them to show
up and now they're trying to say that we
can't hire our own security firms to
bring their firearms even if they're
off-duty officers it was just an
absolute debacle and I can imagine how
terrible that must feel if you're some
inner-city kid from Harlem trying to
protect yourself or your family right
look I mean it's interesting you bring
up guns and schools you know I'm just
incredibly frustrated by the debate that
we're having right now on gun control
we've had these horrible tragedies I for
twenty years have been yelling we need
to do something about it but the gun
control advocates the types of proposals
they put forward would have nothing to
do with stopping these attacks if
anything they might make things worse so
you have things like background checks
on private transfers of guns it's within
an hour and a half of the shooting in
Florida at the high school you had this
Senator Bill Nelson they're calling for
background checks on private transfers
after each of the mass public shootings
during the Obama presidency that the
Obama talked about that was the one law
that he pushed for right well I would
love somebody to tell me one mass public
shooting this century that would have
been stopped as a result of having such
a law because it doesn't exist and yet
that's the first thing out of the box
that they have you know we want to go
and increase the age for people owning
guns to 21 well you know obviously there
was a horrible thing where a 19 year old
killed many people but their costs and
benefits of any of these changes what
about a 20 year old woman who's being
stalked
what is she is supposed to do having a
gun is by far the safest course of
action for her to take when she's in
that type of position and you know you
want to try to measure what the net
effect of these types of things are and
there's no discussion what we do know
what we do know matters is that all the
mass public shootings in Florida every
single one in 98 percent of the mass
public shootings since 1950 in the
United States have something in common
that is they keep on occurring in places
where general citizens are banned from
having guns for protection right
these killers may be crazy in some sense
but they're not stupid they know that
they can go and kill more people if
there's nobody there to go and protect
themselves you know anybody who's read
any my work knows that I think police
are extremely important stopping crime I
think that there's single most important
factor but having one police officer in
uniform guarding a school or some place
else is an impossible task having
somebody in uniform it's like having
somebody with a neon sign above them
that says go and shoot me first
if you're a killer going to go and do an
attack you know if you can kill that
officer you have free rein foregoing
killing people because he's going to be
the only one that's going to have a gun
to go and stop you the benefit from
having concealed carry for teachers or
staff that's there is that it takes away
the strategic advantage that these
killers have because they don't know who
it is that they have to go and take out
first and and the other frustrating
thing about this debate is that so much
of the gun control debate is about
things that might possibly go wrong
so when senator Rubio had that Town Hall
on CNN basically cuz my work I'm forced
to watch this yeah exactly were the
enemy has chastised all of them him and
Dana lash and said will you promise to
ban all semi-automatic weapons if not we
have nothing at DISA cause I can you
can't just tell him what he has to say
let the guy talk it was embarrassing
yeah right well he was asked about
letting staff or teachers be able to go
and carry and his response absolutely no
way he had talked to some relatives of
his who were teachers and they were
worried that if you let a teacher carry
a gun and they stopped a mass public
shooting that as soon as the police
arrived the police would end up shooting
the teacher well the problem is we don't
need to guess about these types of
things right I go to our website at
crime research or we have dozens of
cases in the last few years where either
police sheriff's or prosecutors have
pointed to cases where a permit holder
has stopped a mass
shooting where multiple people would
have died sir and you can look at these
cases in recent years and you don't find
one single case where that type of
concern has occurred there's not one
case when the police have arrived that
they've shot the permit holder another
big concern that you hear about is well
maybe the permit holder will
accidentally shoot a bystander when
they're trying to stop the killer there
there's not one of those cases you know
are these things possible sure they're
possible but at least it would be
something more for us to focus on if you
could actually point to examples where
something like that has occurred rather
than bringing up pasta I'll give you one
other example of this after 9/11 I was
asked by several the airline pilots
unions to help them be able to go and
carry guns with them on planes to
protect in case terrorist attacks and I
didn't know some of these details before
I started helping them but you know
you'd go into like a senator's office
and the senator would go and raise
concerns about well what happens if both
the pilots have guns and they get into
an argument and they shoot each other
and you have a locked door and you have
two dead pilots what are you gonna do
that
and a double homicide at the same time
like it's like right III where they're
going there and they Bray at the Bell
knock each other out yeah I know it's
these what is they get into the realm of
the absurd well the thing is what most
people don't know is from 1923 until
1963 all commercial airline pilots in
the United States were mandated to carry
a loaded handgun with them at all times
it's a type of rule that went into
effect back in the early 20s because the
US Postal Service started hiring planes
to carry the mail and you know you have
a biplane crash in a cornfield someplace
they wanted to make sure that the pilot
could go and guard the mail and keep it
from being stolen and they didn't know
you know you wouldn't know and tell
maybe the last moment whether the plane
would be carrying mail so they mandated
it right well 40 years later they still
had the same rule in effect and but the
thing is and then until 1979 they were
allowed to carry a gun if they wanted to
have done
kills two dead pilots and cockpits and
he no no not even in fact in fact you
can find with hundreds of millions of
flights you can't find one single case
where where a pilot committed a crime
with his concealed with his handgun
there you can find a few dozen cases
where the pilots actually use their guns
to stop crimes from occurring but you
know and if that was and that was in the
30s or 40s those pilots were drunk I
think it is remarkable isn't it funny
that we just we talked about Australia
in the UK where they take these very
very weak correlations to attribute
causation but when you say hold on a
second in the United States ninety-eight
percent of all mass shootings occurring
in gun-free zones and you can't point to
any crimes you're talking ago well
causation correlation I don't know III
I'm a little Merkin by the way rocky -
I'd miss quoted I know is gonna be fact
checked on that I had to correct myself
it was rocky - I heard yeah I don't know
it's no examples of these at all and the
hypothetical if you get into those
examples right it what if they killed a
bystander well on a second 16 were
killed anyway at this point even if we
were to get into the hypotheticals and
say let's engage on this it still
wouldn't be a worse scenario than there
are right now one thing that I've talked
about and I know you've written a lot of
research like you've talked about on
campus I think our president overstepped
saying that teachers should have to
carry firearms or anyone proposing that
but I certainly think that concealed
carry holders who happen to be teachers
should be allowed to carry if they can
carry at the supermarket if they can
carry in their everyday life I think
they should be allowed to carry as
teachers I think that's a micro step in
the right direction
yeah now that to varying degrees have
teachers and staff carry in Texas you're
mentioning Texas earlier as of last fall
they had 172 school districts in Texas
where staff and teachers carry in Ohio
you have over a hundred school districts
in Utah
it looks like about five percent of the
teachers actively carry and about 10 to
12 percent of the sport staff carry you
know you look across these 18 states if
one of these states one of these
teachers had a situation where they lost
control of a gun and somebody had gotten
ahold of it it would get massive
national news coverage if you had
external gun deaths that had occurred
they've got massive accident massive
national news coverage that are there
for K through 12 there's one case in
Utah where a teacher
a few years ago accidentally after
school hours fired her permit a
concealed handgun and killed the toilet
she accidentally shot a toilet in the
bathroom
it was an embarrassing toilet situation
before she shot it that was her ticket
out she's like think fact say I'll just
shoot it that's less embarrassing that
what occurred in here Negus the
discharge who knows but you know and
that's if you you know there's a couple
other cases but those are when there
have like firearms training classes
outside of school hours on school
property if you have firearms training
classes and people are handling the gun
that's a completely different type of
situation than when you're talking about
you know actual kind of normal school
situations that are going on and you
know it's it seems like we should be
able to have an easy debate on this type
of thing but it's something that's
really not even considered in terms of
looking at the experience at these other
places have had I'd I'd love to live in
a world where there's not violence but
given that we do what we're going to do
to try to stop this and you know and
it's just not you have statements from
these killers about why they picked the
targets that they did you know they
understand themselves I you know people
may have heard about the Aurora Batman
movie theater shooter and the statements
he left or the Charleston Church shooter
about why they picked the targets they
had other targets but they were worried
about security or other people having
guns at those places you have case that
probably people I haven't heard about
about a year and a half or so ago there
was a case in Detroit where father was
concerned about his son's involvement
with Isis had gone and contact the FBI
the FBI
recorded his telephone
they have an amazingly chilly
conversation where this person is
explained to a compete reott why he had
picked one of the largest churches in
the Detroit area to attack that he had
checked and this church had banned
anybody from having permanent concealed
handguns on church property and he
explained to his compatriot that that
made it easier for him to kill lots of
people before anybody could arrive and
you look at the statistical evidence on
this stuff you know right-to-carry
states like Texas or Florida or you know
Pennsylvania whatever you're able to go
and carry your perm a concealed handgun
in 97 98 99 percent of the state and yet
these attacks to the extent that they
keep on occurring keep on occurring in
those tiny areas within the state where
people aren't allowed to have guns right
you know the Batman movie theater
shooter you had seven movie theaters
showing the premiere of the Batman movie
within a 20-minute Drive of the killer's
apartment only one of those movie
theaters posted signs banning permitted
concealed handguns he didn't go to the
one that was closest to his home he
didn't go to the one they had the
largest auditoriums in the state he went
to the one that posted signs banning
people from having guns for protection
right the Lafayette movie theater the
same thing you look at the mall attacks
you you know Omaha Nebraska you've like
eight enclosed malls only one posted
signs it was the one that was farthest
from the killer's home that's the one he
goes to similar story with the Kansas
City Mall shooting with the Salt Lake
City Mall shooting the Portland Oregon
mall shooting it's almost reflect on
that 98% gun free statistic as though
they go out of their way they're fine
they're mentally ill but not that
mentally ill right they're mentally ill
but acute yes because they and they have
good transportation I guess they're
probably not taking public transit
because you can't carry public transit
this is very interesting no obviously
the book is the war on guns we have to
get going but crime research org is
where people can go let me ask you this
final question before we go I've always
said this was the gun control debate
right now in this country particularly
if you look at the recent assault
weapons ban proposal
if you look at the dissenting opinions
with hella vs. DC arguing private
citizens have no right to carry firearms
whatsoever we never hear no right
exactly
it's it's it's insane it's really is
scary that we're one vote away from that
but um I've always said there's there's
the the Battle of the informed and
people who know nothing about firearms
that's kind of this discussion now there
are other political gray areas firearm
ownership is not one of them why do you
think then the media New York Times yeah
why are they so hell-bent on pushing gun
control why do you think that is closing
thought you know I think people
including people in the media get
impacted by the media coverage over time
if you constant I mean I know my views
have changed a lot over the years that
I've been doing this research I was
probably as affected by the media
coverage as much as anybody else if you
constantly hear about bad things that
happen with guns and never hear about
the benefits or rarely do who can you
blame for having much more negative
views as I say in recent years I have
dozens of cases where mass public
shootings have been stopped by concealed
carry permit holders these cases just
don't get national news coverage some of
them are dramatic cases a couple I even
Minh doing the heroic action when I've
gone to news bureaus saying for sure
they'll cover it with the film here I've
been told well it would just be
political for us to go and run a story
on this you know it just you trot out
the kids from Florida you know a
chilling example we did this on in and
out on a Dallas campus where we asked
people this was right after parkland
Florida they talked about that shooting
we asked these same students they were
about three hours away from the
Sutherland Springs shooting we had
Steven Wilford on this show before any
other news show because no one else was
probably going to give him a fair shake
this guy stopped them he was an NRA
certified instructor for people who
don't know stop the bad guy with an
ar-15 who shot up a church more deadly
than parkland Florida we asked the
students with us at UT Dallas where was
it yeah UT Dallas I think it was UT
Dallas I might be mistaken I don't know
it was SMU TCU as UT they all knew about
parkland I asked him if they'd heard of
the Sutherland Springs shooting
not a single student even knew about it
and no one about even Wilford yeah look
I mean I give you tons of examples you
have the pulse nightclub shooting that
occurred in Florida Florida's one of the
one ten states that ban permit concealed
handguns in nightclubs ten days after
the pulse shooting where forty nine
people were killed there was an attack
that occurred at a nightclub in South
Carolina the difference is is that South
Carolina allows people to carry permit
concealed handguns in nightclubs the
shooter had wounded three people
apparently he had like a hundred rounds
of ammunition on him and he was
continuing to fire at that point
concealed carry permit holder pulled out
his gun and seriously wounded the
attacker there's like no national news
coverage I thought for sure given the
sensitivity we just had about mass
public shooting a nightclub just ten
days earlier in Florida this would get
some national news coverage you can get
quotes from therefore the the local
sheriff saying that he's convinced that
if the permit holder wasn't there there
would have been a lot of fatalities that
would have occurred and then you know
would have gotten national news coverage
so so there are two things one is the
fact that the media just doesn't have
any symmetry in terms of how it covers
these things but to also the facts that
they cover so my guess is the entire gun
debate right now would be dramatically
different if even once in a while the
media would say things like well we had
another mass public shooting at a place
where people were banned from having
guns you know people would be going to
save geez that seems to be something
that happens a lot with this and and I
think it would make a real difference in
the debate but it's often the easiest
fact for them to check you know they
report other things like the type of gun
that was used or how the person obtained
the gun and they'll frequently get those
initial reports wrong yeah those are
much more difficult things to find out
quickly you know even if even if you
don't look up the law if you just have
pair binoculars you can see whether the
movie theater has a posted sign out
front or not there even if they can't
close to the movie even just the recent
YouTube shooting it's one of those
things I find it's the Huff posted this
is the face of domestic terrorism and
there was Dylan roof YouTube stream they
have a picture of the police officer and
it says suspect being held no motive yet
one we don't need the motive show the
picture of the suspect of course it was
an Iranian PETA vegan activist and
pretty sure pretty sure Google YouTube
gun-free zone certainly in that area you
can say that cuz Don Lemon has an
opinion exactly because Don Lemon
sitting there he's influenced by the
media he's going well this this
statistic comes ghosts of dead Gemma's
Wow Wow no you know San Francisco County
I'm not sure if this was in San
Francisco County or the county right
below it but San Francisco County for
many years would have won concealed
carry permit holder or two but the one
that had it was the sheriff's personal
lawyer he was the one person in the
county who is allowed to go and carry a
permit concealed handgun yeah it's not
just it's not like they'd be going to a
target where people are going to be able
to go and protect themselves it is it is
a sad state of affairs that is again
John lot you can follow them on the
Twitter at John our lot jr. the book is
the war on guns
highly recommended crime research org
mister lot thank you for taking the time
sir I really appreciate it and hopefully
some people have learned something new
today thank you again thank you did you
like this video of course you did let's
there's something wrong with you in
which case you can comment below what's
your problem with this video we want to
hear from you and we promise you 100% I
give you my word is my bond will answer
every single negative comment for those
who are normal you can leave a thumbs up
and subscribe